[Musique]
jacques son nom est désormais connu dans
le monde entier harry potter le jeune
sorcier de jk rowling une aventure
commencée en 1998 avec un premier tome
il ya 20 ans harry entrée à l'école des
sorciers
[Musique]
cher monsieur potter nous avons le
plaisir de vous informer que vous êtes
admis qu au collège poudlard l'école de
sorcellerie à saint-quentin-en-yvelines
ses fans sont venus célébrer cet
anniversaire aux couleurs de la saga
j'ai la robe des sorciers de bad trip
runner 3g la baguette d'harry potter
j'ai les lunettes d'harry potter la
cicatrice de harry potter et gels et
gère des téléphones heure là c'est ce
pion ou la salle en français et c'est
l'association d'hermione pour la défense
des elfes de maison et ça c'est une
baguette fait part ces petits soins
toujours c'est une baguette qui
inspirait par la baguette de sirius
black répartition dans les maisons à
l'aide du choix peau atelier
calligraphie pour réaliser son blason
différents ateliers mis en place par
cette enseigne de sqy ouest
je crois que larry potter ça a changé
toute une génération que sur 15 20 ans
tous les jeunes on a été transformé par
ce petit sorcier et il a vécu un peu la
vie qu'on a tous envie de vivre donc
voilà ça me fait rêver
une saga qui poursuit sa conquête
l'univers harry potter continue de vivre
au travers de films comme les animaux
fantastiques sortie en 2016
il avait attiré près de 4 millions de
spectateurs dans les salles françaises
un âge quand les normes agents peur est
il apte à régler ça où ce sera la guerre